la nouvelle s'est confirmé tôt ce matin
quand ces convois ont quitté la prison
les photos vos de moscou pour se rendre
à l'aéroport
il a fallu attendre que l'avion se pose
à kiev pour comprendre la véritable
ampleur de la transaction un moment
émouvant que ces familles attendaient
depuis très longtemps retrouver leur
fils les embrasser il est ramené à la
maison
les 24 marins ukrainiens sont sortis les
premiers puis le cinéaste l'ex n stuff
qu'ils étaient en prison depuis cinq ans
dans le nord de la russie
quel bonheur de retrouver ma terre
natale merci à tous ceux qui se sont
battus dit il au pied de l'avion le
président volodymyr hélène ce qui les a
reçus les flots il s'agit d'un premier
pas d'un premier chapitre important dit
il c'est en effet une première victoire
diplomatique pour lui mais elle a coûté
cher car parmi ceux qu'ils livrent à la
russie il y à cet homme volodymyr sémard
il est un témoin clé de l'explosion du
vol m h 17 de la malaysian airlines qui
effectuait la liaison amsterdam kuala
lumpur
quand il a été abattu en 2014 au dessus
de l'ukraine par un missile russe les
pays bas auront tout fait pour
convaincre une crainte de ne pas le
rendre
mais en vain d'ailleurs le président
vladimir poutine n'était pas l'aéroport
à moscou pour accueillir les siens mais
déclaraient pas plus tard que jeudi
cet échange monumental les mener vers la
normalisation des relations entre les
deux pays du pays qui se livrent depuis
l'annexion de la crimée par la russie
une gare hybride sanglante et volodymyr
et lens qui n'a pas hésité pour dire que
selon lui la prochaine étape devrait
être avec la russie plusieurs pays dont
l'allemagne les états unis et la france
ont salué cet échange historique qui
pourrait éventuellement mener à la fin
de la guerre entre les forces
chrétiennes les séparatistes pro-russes
une guerre qui alimente depuis des
années les tensions entre l'occident et
la russe est aujourd'hui une rencontre
entre poutine et zelensky et non
seulement envisageable
elle pourrait à la demande du président
macron survenir d'ici quelques semaines
ici tu amaral thérèse coraggio canada